[Music]
well i wanted to get to this
um now
some people are saying now i don't know
if this is true but i wanted to bring it
by you we have a couple different things
here today a little update here on the
brendan stuff
um some people are saying that this was
uh this is recent recently on one of his
shows that rogan was referring to
talking about brendan shop now you tell
me what you think okay i always want to
know like whenever it's like i had a
conversation just yesterday with a good
friend of mine
and we were talking and he was telling
me about the story i'll go okay
do you know for sure that that's how he
took it like maybe he took it this way
did you ask him this first did this like
i want to know did you do this work
are you just assuming you want you want
to call me and tell me that you and this
guy got in an argument because you want
me to tell you you're right or do you
want my actual opinion the only way i
want to get my actual opinion is i need
to know what your opinion is and the
only way i can trust your opinion is if
you've looked at your own self so if you
tell me i got in a fight with this guy
man
i sat down i thought about i was like
okay was i being a dick what did i do
wrong um and then i thought well no
because he knew this and i know he knew
this because he brought this up so
maybe
maybe i didn't uh explain myself right
and so then i'll think about how i
explain myself and i was like well maybe
they misinterpreted what i was saying
they thought i was joking around then
i'll try to think of that i'll do the
work so if i ask someone a question if
they're having an argument with someone
okay do you know of this and then they
start raising their voice and now [ __ ]
him okay
now do you do we i don't think he's
talking about brendan
i think he's talking about brian
okay because that part where he just
goes but then instead of answering these
questions he starts raising his voice
yeah and he's and that seemed doesn't
that seem like something callan would do
because he admits that
all these criticisms seem like they
would be levied accountant like did you
use your cool your [ __ ]
did you not think about this first yeah
it feels like this is more especially
after everything we've seen it feels
like this is definitely more towards
calendar i haven't done the work
so you don't even know so you're you're
so attached to being correct here that
you're ready to dig your heels in the
sand and then fight for your side
regardless of whether or not it's
correct
that's twitter
that's twitter in a nutshell
so that's pretty much that so
i really do think he was referring to
callan when i heard this because i was
like that doesn't seem like something
shaw would do
but there is a couple updates
from already it's like every day there's
more updates
um
[Music]
this is trash tuesday
with kala and then there's also annie
and esther the aptly named trash just i
don't i don't know what any of this is
um i don't watch this normally so i
couldn't tell you annie leaderman is one
of the ones that brendan had on and she
used to date uh madsker
can i say this
i will say
that
uh kala kind of [ __ ] destroyed
brendan oh yeah i mean she
well did she destroy him or did she just
tell the truthful story and he was
trying not to tell the whole story i
guess that's a good point all right
let's see
[Music]
wait i know we're going all over the
place but i'm dying to ask you something
um you had
shob on tiger belly yesterday who's this
i don't know okay
can you please tell me wow that's the
first time we've heard his name on this
podcast ever it's never been brought up
wow but can you tell us what happened i
want to be like super
like kind about this whole thing because
i can watch this
yeah yeah just just
122 000 so far three broads
yapping yep the view the views on tv
does it did take a lot for him to
sit in front of us um i
i gotta tell you probably one of
the most boring episodes we've ever done
um only because it's like there was
hardly any laughs i've seen your other
ones i mean don't sell yourself short
you're not exactly setting the world on
fire in the first place yeah don't sell
yourself short there babe it was so
tense it was very uncomfortable
and um
i didn't
i wish that
i was going in there thinking that he
was just that's kind of funny
domo creole just said trash tuesday more
like vocal friday
that's actually pretty funny
take responsibility for everything but
there was one piece of information that
vocal friday is very good right it took
a little bit it sneaks up on you that
was a good one yeah i felt
i wonder what frozen would say about
that when he was around
i don't know i guess we don't know i'm
not dead okay probably would have
sandbagged it yeah
like i still have a big like mistrust
for him so we have a long way to go
really even after you had him on yeah
and we talked about it on the show i
think like you know i don't have any ill
feeling towards him anymore but there's
still a lot of mistrust and only because
you know i he's still not willing to
admit that
um what we said on the show ultimately
led to the whole spectacle
that became the reddit accusation he's
saying those are two different
occurrences and i will agree with her
here
they are not but they're about to get
into something here in one second i feel
like i'm sitting in a coffee shop and
i'm like 30 seconds away from being like
hey can you guys shut the [ __ ] up yeah
or talk more you know there's other
people here right oh my god it's 8 00
a.m
it is
8 in the morning
[ __ ] i'm trying to write my script my
manuscript on my laptop
has a planned parenthood sticker on his
macbook that he's typing
adjusting a scarf can you keep it down
i'm trying to sell prepaid legal and i
use the starbucks as my office because i
don't really have one hey can you relax
this is the only place i could use wi-fi
to upload my only fans content
thank you
okay these people i'm trying to sell
solar panels to don't know i work out of
my house yes so i meet them here and act
like the office is being renovated
i buy them coffee they think i'm a big
spender
all right anyway
sorry look what she says at the
beginning of this is is that joke of
like so first time his name's been
brought up on the show this is the only
one part where i go brendan does have a
point they're saying they never said his
name but they're saying it was unfunny
comic so right there that's a dead
giveaway they also said bs
brendan schaub and then their own who
else is it gonna be then they joke bob
saget but it wasn't bob saget so
that's my point it's like they're
they're they're trying to get away look
i would respect them to go yeah we did
say you're unfunny we're allowed to say
that who cares you know
but what bothers me
is that they're pretending like
oh no we never said your name well you
said bs and you said unfunny and
you we know who you were talking about
we're not idiots
um but i do just now i disagree with
brendan on this part i do think it's
connected i think that this all the
reason they jumped to them was because
they said it was connected yes but i'm
like
the timing is very strange because it
was only a couple days after our live
show that
the the the reddit accusations came out
and the slandering came out so we're not
there yet i think that we have a long
way to go before like we fully like
have some type of
uh i don't know like goodness between us
but i do respect that
you know
i appreciate that he had the balls to
come on the show okay but can you tell
me then like what did come out of it
like what did he own up to i wish he had
the balls to come on this show because
okay sass queen can you shut up
i still after hearing um
him talk to
everyone except me about it i she has
the chonga [ __ ] eye makeup
i realized i did misinterpret her today
she misinterpreted it she's interpreter
so are they all mushmouth idiots over
there so it's not just sharks are you
sure you didn't suck brendan shop's dick
and get some of that cte come in your
mouth yeah it's cte std
and i
when he i watched the did you watch the
fighter and the kid i did not i don't
want to well i you know i didn't realize
he was being so bullied that he was
afraid for his life is what he was
saying and i guess when he asked me to
walk to the truck he wasn't
wanting to do sexual favors i'm so
embarrassed by that but he needed like
an escort because he was scared that the
haters were going to come
okay that's
kind of brutal
okay can i take can i say that that's
hold on that's kind of brutal can i say
something here
bravo can i give her credit
can we give her credit she deadpanned
that too she did she knows all that to
the end
hey
bravo who's is this one esther
no that's annie lederman oh i don't know
their names
so uh i only know this one as kurt
metzger's ex okay
well very funny
very funny
is he still writing for you
now i'm kidding now i'm the one that's
joking
now i'm the one that's joking i'm the
one that's kidding we're just having
some fun here we're all joking
and i actually guys i actually made a
petition to not be mean on the internet
anymore that's it
[Laughter]
it's just one piece of purple paper
taped to a [ __ ] thing i mean this is
kind of funny this is very funny out of
everything we've seen content-wise from
all of this this one's making me laugh i
mean remember he was the one that was
like is that nice
was that it yes remember that yes yes
i think we should no be mean on the
internet i have stickers there's
different colors you can use no more
mean on the internet especially to these
good guys because
they are just trying to fight for
freedom of speech and so if you say mean
things about them i'm going to make sure
this gets to elon musk and we're going
to stop this right
i feel like
you're making this worse this isn't
helping i don't think i don't think
we're this is a to use an analogy a very
cliche analogy this is like throwing
gasoline on the fire
yeah
yeah
yeah
so
if anybody wants to sign it i've got
different colored
crayons and stickers you can choose from
your favorite colors so sorry but i have
to ask so
i'm just curious so they
they're scared yes it was because they
were bullied that they were able to
bully others
that's
very sound logic that is kind of
you know when you put it that way
that is sort of what they did
or very much right on the target what
they did yeah god damn it she's she's
this one's oh no she's actually fun
she's pretty good i got to tell you i
never really seen her stuff so i don't
know
oh because they were being bullied and i
misinterpreted it and i am
misinterpreted at it that's fine
do i put like listen i know it's gonna
take a while but i hope you don't know
why she's dressed like a fly girl
she really does look like she's about to
[ __ ] come out to a dance number on
[ __ ] yeah
do you forgive me she looks like that or
she looks like
a a a nitro girl but when they were
traveling at the airport like yeah when
they were dressed up for the show like
just if you ran into a nitro girl at the
airport in 1997. she looks like a
stripper eating breakfast at a waffle
house
you always spot them because there's
always three of them at a table and then
like one dude yeah and they're all just
you're like those are obviously
strippers
she didn't even take her eyelashes
there's glitter everywhere there's
glitter all over my southwest omelette
it's all over and i hope we can move on
i have
lit nothing for love but you and
yes so i misinterpreted it's very
embarrassing
i did ask him i said brendan i was like
you got to come on our show like you've
got to i think you've got to talk to
annie this is what he said he's like
kyla just please not this week
he's just
she's taking a beating
a dessert
they have their knives out for him right
now like they're not [ __ ] around
notice that none of them are even
talking about callan anymore
they're it's him
i didn't know they were oh
look look i want to apologize i want to
apologize okay because yeah did i call
annie leaderman last week until i was
gonna break her [ __ ] head open huh
split her head open like a [ __ ]
overripe grapefruit okay yeah i did that
i own that dude
because i own that bro i'm sitting
indian style but you can't see it
there's also mercer is also wearing sand
but let me finish let me like yeah yo
but b okay b so i guy overreacted b i
overreacted b when i saw what andy
lederman was saying i said listen i will
i will [ __ ] your throat till you're dead
you [ __ ] [ __ ] and i and now i'm gonna
own that i'm gonna own that part of it
you'll be it was nobody but me you know
i got a black belt in haters right
but let me let me let me finish all
right so i was way too hopped up on like
[ __ ] hymns
and [ __ ] bang energy
okay
and i'm really like bent out of shape
because i look i went through a divorce
i'm really [ __ ] sick right now i'm
doing [ __ ] sick bro
so i might have told annie lederman i
was gonna ass [ __ ] her with a butcher
knife but that was to protect my friend
you were being masking you were being
masculine you were being masculine
you're not helping me right now okay
hey
fighter in the kid folks
uh well
that's a bit of that but this part this
we have to play this
this was the beginning of the next tiger
belly episode
we know why you're here you want to know
what happened after the podcast last
week so here is a quick follow-up to
that episode
as of today we have not seen said 300
pages of documents after the podcast we
were shown a couple of zoomed in
screenshots of source code with no
contacts our email address is in the
corner of one screenshot and the name
robert lee on the corner of another
screenshot when we asked him who sent
these to him he said brian we then asked
to be connected to his team directly to
get further clarity and he assured us
that he would make that happen we
followed up with him for the next three
days and finally on thursday we received
a text from brennan saying his team
would prefer to handle this issue
in-house
then why did you say you were going to
show it to them these 300 pages you said
you were
and does not feel comfortable sharing
information with tiger belly
to recap
we have not received any substantial
evidence regarding the accusations we
have not been in contact with a team all
we've seen are some screenshots sent to
sure
this is all over reddit posts
yeah
yeah
this is all over 100 people being mean
on reddit 100 all over reddit posts yes
how does
how does anyone get to a point where
they have enough money in a good enough
career and they're they they're actually
tying up this much energy and effort and
focus on mean reddit posts
they're never gonna go away
and you're only gonna make them multiply
um i will say this to quote tim robinson
what does that do for the greater good
what does that do for the greater good
it was your idea you said it was funny i
said it was interesting
we're hoping to get some closure on this
but that's probably not going to happen
the good news is
we have a great episode today and we'd
like to start by thanking our sponsor i
would love to see the video metrics of
this
it's
all front loaded people want to know the
update and then everything's going to be
downhill from there
because uh from my understanding
um i think everyone needs to just
not let this go
you know it looks up your body what am i
asked all right so you know um
i have to say
in terms of uncomfortable podcasts i've
done in my life oh right
that rivaled the carlos mancillo one
okay to be fair i will agree with him
because that was a rough one because he
was calling him out for stealing
ooh
the carlos
for me very uncomfortable i don't like
that he has his own frozen asian right
that's kind of weird kind of yeah weird
what is that about i missed forever that
makes me miss him a lot
i'm still here
hey ghost of frozen asian what is he
asian or is he polynesian i can't tell
with this guy
um he's filipino philippi i knew it see
i'm starting to catch it it's frozen
look see other shows are ripping off our
style and i don't like it well i mean
look it's it's very easy to figure out
if they're asian but they're kind of
mexican looking they're always filipino
yeah that's true that's true that's true
well that's not fair though because
mexicans can eat spicy food
because i love
ned you know i mean and um that was
difficult to experience this was
just as uncomfortable i i kind of
observed something uh about shaub and
this is not a negative thing is that
when the cameras are on he really is
sort of he has an error about him that
is he's a certain way but when the
cameras are off because he stayed for
another hour afterwards great
conversation he's a lot more relaxed and
a lot more human and a lot more
like
down to earth then he would seem on
camera
big sweetie pie bud
so
so we're just gonna go back to
pretending everybody's cool i mean i
don't know if it's cool because they did
that thing at the beginning but anyone
in a bathroom but do you know how
bugging technology works what if it's
able to like listen to you i want you to
be amber heard now go ahead
very unhappy in the house it's been
disastrous
it's been just depressing and um
well this is now airing a week after
i mean
it's behind us tbd tbd dvd um
but you know but then didn't you just go
on that broad show
well this is what happened yacking like
a bunch of broads again i think they
recorded this entire episode before
they recorded the beginning part of the
episode because that was a voiceover
where he was saying like they never
showed us they never showed us the
the papers you know their team wants to
handle it so i think that's why because
this is like a week out and they record
it then that goes up a week out
so i think that that other part was
added at the beginning i'm like her
going on the chick show
i mean her going on that trash tuesday
yeah well she's always on trash tuesdays
that's like one of that's her show too
from what i understand but she was just
over there
doing that i understand and i think that
show was recorded after this one after
they found out brendan said he wasn't
going to give us oh okay do you
understand what i'm saying like that's
that seems to be the order of the way
they were recorded
my point is look my point is this
i will agree with you
this is a very dumb reason right a very
[ __ ] dumb reason
to be fighting
over reddit post but the problem is is
that the moment that you have an
investigative team now right
that's like going after the truth and
you you're hiring like
you know
showing them like he said they show them
a paper with html code which what does
that mean
but it's also this thing where it's like
they want like
they get this
shitty non-proof
and then they go running to somebody and
they're like i'm gonna [ __ ] end you
and it's like all over this hearsay and
reddit post it's like
if somebody came to me and said i've got
a whole bunch of ip addresses and i
could prove that adonis paul's running a
[ __ ] reddit channel dedicated to
[ __ ] messing with you and blah blah
blah no but he told me he's doing that
anyway so he's upfront about it so there
you go but no but like
you either ask nicely to somebody hey is
this true you know i don't think it is
whatever or you go
yeah i don't really care i mean if he is
then [ __ ] him like you know what i mean
like
i have no reason to believe that and i'm
still cool with him
if he is doing that then [ __ ] him but
like
other than [ __ ] him how far do you want
to take this like yeah other than just
hey you know uh merch was talking some
[ __ ] about you the other day was he all
right well [ __ ] him then that should be
[Music]
most of the [ __ ] in life should be able
to just roll off your back you should be
able to go oh okay is he just pretending
to like me and he doesn't really like me
[ __ ] that guy then you know what i mean
but not
call him and go i'll [ __ ] i'm gonna get
brian callan call you and threaten to
snap your neck so i guess this is what
they consider by the way moving on of
this this mean bullying online and it
was affecting them so much and i'm so
sorry to contribute to that and that's
why this petition will be sent to elon
musk i am so sorry
that this happened to them that they
were so scared that they had to commit a
fight i know comedy is hard
you just didn't you just signed with a
heart yeah i'm just sending love pete
did you want to sign criminals i think
you should pass this on to the crew
oh god no more bullying behind the
scenes you guys do you hear me
kalyala no more [ __ ] i don't think
this is making it better this doesn't
feel like it's a good thing i feel like
this has been resolved yeah at all
really
no more calling and threatening it's
just i will continue to tell stories i
want i have no interest in me tooing
anyone nobody did anything wrong i don't
care if anyone hits on me i really don't
even care if anyone hits on me that
wasn't the point i was making a point
anonymously if i wanted the clicks for
it and the drama i would have said the
person's name i still am not saying
their name um
because this was not my intention at all
but i am allowed to tell a story that's
interesting to me and i think is like
relatable and to any woman in a
workplace yes well here's what i'll say
to anyone
bro women [ __ ] saw guys are terrible
why do you like this i know i get that
all the time like merchants women or
what merch's problem is but like
a lot of people could never really make
like sell me on the fact that women
don't [ __ ] suck the other one was
doing so well on her own and then this
one's got to come in like any woman in
the workplace shut up
just just just just shut up